he's a bad employee Nathan Drake is a
bad employee am ia bad employee you are
on the verge of being fired almost every
day this is versus the GameSpot show
that pits your favorite games consoles
franchises and hot-button issues against
each other this week is the Battle of
the Indiana clones as we pit mega
franchise tomb raider against Sony's
fortune and glory and charted fighting
for tomb raider is tomorrow Sain who
aside from having loved the franchise
from the beginning had way too much fun
at this Tomb Raider experience day and
arguing the case for uncharted is Oscar
Deus who coincidentally is cosplaying as
the young Nathan Drake from enchanted 3
for today's episode each going to argue
the corner for their game over the
course of three randomly picked topics
with the overall winner being decided by
you though wonderful viewers last week's
fight between The Witcher 3 and Zelda
breath the wild saw me notch up my first
win with 68% of the vote from my Witcher
3 arguments and rightly bloody so to
vote on this week's episode we're going
to be throwing up a clickable poll right
here on YouTube vote for who you think
argued their case better by clicking the
little I in the top right corner at any
point during the video and casting your
vote or if you're watching this on
gamespot caramel as know who you think
is won the debate in the comments
section below right let's get into it
well you're gonna spend the rest of the
next 15 minutes moaning and telling me
how the world is against you and how you
hate life that's what I would do I'd
rather have a moaner than someone who
just that indiscriminately kills people
and has the worst dress sense I've seen
we talked about looking at you this man
what a mess game play Corvette is the
first category all right and it's pretty
clear to me that untie it has far
superior gameplay you made it because
the the biggest compliment you can pay
to two motors gameplay is that it's like
uncharted but not as good the climbing
is better
there's even open-world elements now in
uncharted Lost legacy which Tomb Raider
tried and sort of did really
half-heartedly that's the problem I have
with with everything that to murder does
like the modern series in particular it
does everything so how fast Italy like
the climbing is fine but not as good as
uncharged even like the jumps feel
really kind of like magnetic so
everything about your to murder is so
half-hearted and just not refined well
enough it's like uncharted for an entire
lost legacy in particular are so well
we're fine you can you can feel the
quality
firstly let's just put it out there I'm
trying wouldn't exist without Tomb
Raider in terms of gameplay
I don't think uncharged gameplay is as
strong as people remember it to be I
feel like it's elevated by everything
else that Naughty Dog does really well
which is characterization in the world
and to some extent the story the
gameplay itself feels bog-standard to me
in every in every way like the the
shootings never felt good to me
untried is all about shooting guns and
moving around to murder is about more of
like an uphill struggle in terms of
combat in gameplay you've got various
tools available to you I don't even
remember using guns all that much I
remember using a bow and arrow which was
super satisfying creating like Molotov
cocktails on the fly based on what was
around me to marys one's about having a
certain set of enemies placing them in a
certain way and then you approaching
that scenario and thinking about what
have I got what is around me and how can
I get this done within the better
quickest and the most like for me in the
quietest way possible I don't think I've
ever felt challenged in any sort of
meaningful way by
troit same for the combat same for the
climbing and the puzzles on trigram
games are great but they're like very
they feel very gamey they're like boom
bombastic moment puzzle shooting
set-piece character whereas too many
feels more cohesive it felt more
cohesive to me it had those moments
where you're surviving and then you you
know you go off the into one of those
folks and then you find that you're in a
like a tomb or like you're in an action
set piece and then you're very natural
you mean just like an try it
that's very we have to say it will very
naturally come back into another
survival moment bring you back to the
main camp area instead of just like
pushing you from one beat to another
where it feels very disjointed and you
can see how it's so important you can
stand back and predict what's gonna
happen we're gonna be like alright I
haven't had an explosion in about 20
minutes one is coming up right now and
then you go into the next area oh my
gosh the chopper pick up the RPG fire
the RPG I hide behind and you're like
alright I get it I get it cool it's dry
man you're dry
alright the next topic we got is
franchise evolution credit where credit
is due like tumor is one of the most
enduring franchises in gaming like you
Laura Croft and tomato they're iconic in
gaming and like I've said before and
I'll say again untried without tomato
doesn't exist it was at the very cusp of
3d gaming like we should not forget that
the idea of having these kind of you
know open environments and being able to
explore them and the idea it's called
Tomb Raider because it appeals to that
that desire for in people to kind of
just explore areas and that's what it
gave and it's always what it continues
to give so from the earlier games the
PlayStation games like those are the
games that really like established the
genre you know the exploration the tomb
raiding and the adventure is in the end
Indiana Jones archetype within
videogames
Loras had my steps as most do but
they've always tried something different
they've explored like darker sides of
archaeology and adventuring and that
kind of stuff they've reached a point
now where I think we've got the best
version of Twitter in I think this is
the game that they always intended what
for it to be this kind of like semi
open-world exploration Metroidvania
style thing
I think tomato will continue to carry on
and it all do that and it will evolve
it's an enduring franchise and it'll be
here long after to
try it I think you're right when you say
that Tomb Raider is enduring and how its
you know it's clearly been around for a
lot longer than uncharted and I think
you're right when you say that Tomb
Raider is in the best place it's ever
been
however the best place that Tomb Raider
has ever been the best that series has
ever managed to achieve is to be a pale
imitation of Uncharted I think if you
look at the way the two series have
evolved over their respective lifetimes
two murders obviously been around for
around about double the amount finder
and charters has been around for and she
has changed all Tomb Raider as a series
has changed more than uncharted has but
that's probably because it's had more
time to change and also because they've
had to change because some of like you
said there's been missteps along the way
whereas there's been no uncharted game
that's been bad and that's why they
haven't really had to change much like
they started off at a pretty good level
and now they've got it to a really good
level and so they haven't had to change
much whereas with Tomb Raider they've
had to they've had to evolve so much
she'll try and avoid these missteps and
the place that they've ended up her is
just below where uncharted is after all
of that innovation again again you're
comparing your again reducing what to
mater is to say it's just below what
enjoy it like if you're if you're
looking at just shooting the fine it's
just below on try it if you're looking
at as an overall broad variety and game
experience like I don't think they're
just but I don't want to rank them but I
don't think it would be two minutes
definitely below untried like tomato
offers in way more it tries to do some
way more maybe that's our necessity
because they've had those missteps but
I'd rather have a game that mate tries
and takes chances than a game that plays
it safe and just offers you the same
thing over and over again
two-minute on Troy it is the safest
series in gaming right now like it
you're guaranteed you know exactly if
they are now stand you on try today you
know exactly what you're gonna get and I
love it and I'm sure it'll be great but
like at the same time they'll be a part
of me that would be like I live there
just gonna do the same thing again I'm
done on our carats at least when they
announced a new on tomato you you have a
chance of be getting sick if you say the
same thing over again this because you
menu same rubbish please shut up you've
been around for double the amount of
time I have as well and look where
you've ended up just below me
your boss Legacy / impact tomorrow now
I'm not going to pretend that uncharted
is as recognizable as UK you call him a
pawn like go against a fact despite how
much everyone loves Nathan Drake he
doesn't come anywhere close to the
recognition that Lara Croft has that I
it's I agree these are par however I
would say even though Lara is far more
recognizable than Nathan Drake to a
wider audience you know my mum doesn't
know who David Drake is for example but
she does know who Lara Croft is and the
reason she knows who Lara Croft is is
because of the Angelina Jolie films
which were terrible the legacy of Tomb
Raider is that it gave birth to a series
of films which were atrocious and now
even though people know what Tomb Raider
is they know it's bad or at least they
think it's bad but if you look at the
box office and the reception they were
treated as good films they did well they
did well enough to spawn sequels and
they did well enough to continue to
convince Hollywood executives and
videogame executives that is worth
pursuing more to meta movies so to you
and me is bad to the rest of the world
you can't just assume that they
associate tomato with some being
something bad now the impact it has had
it's undeniable that Lara Croft is is
she's a videogame icon you can take a
picture of Lara Croft to anyone anywhere
in the world and there's a good chance
I'll go Lara Croft if you take a picture
of Drake to anyone anywhere in the one
they go like saw him in a shopping
centre last week he doesn't have the
lasting legacy he doesn't have the
cultural impact he doesn't have he's not
an ambassador for gaming in the way Lara
Croft is fundamentally she's an icon and
she's an icon for different people for
different reasons I really loved lara
croft because she represented something
a fantasy of exploration and that - made
her friends she was Indiana Jones for
video games you have young girls you
look at her and see her like putting in
the work and coming out on top and doing
her best to fight everyone see something
different in Lara Croft and that's what
makes her such a powerful character I
think the most stark thing about the
legacy of Tomb Raider is the demise of
Tomb Raider and how
you can clearly see how in like in the
90s for example Lara and Tomb Raider was
was an icon they were both icons for
PlayStation and they were something that
everyone knew and now that mantle has
fallen to Nathan Drake like no one I
don't think really cares that much about
Tomb Raider anymore and about Lara Croft
not to the same extent I think there are
still people there still ardent fans of
that series I might be so because it is
a good series but I just don't think
these days I think if you were to ask a
10 year old kid these days oh do you
prefer this series of this series I
think there's only one answer and I
think if you were to ask them do you
prefer this person or this person I
think there's only one answer and I
think going forward even though the
Uncharted series no one's really sure
where it's going to go at the moment if
you assume they're there they are going
to do more games which I think they
probably will because they make a lot of
money from them I think going forward
Uncharted will have a far superior
legacy both in terms of its reputation
and in terms of its reach than Tomb
Raider 2 meter the only the thing that
holds you back from the whole thing that
like is that the perception issue he has
is because it's so you know storied and
old and like my Celtic were you sharp
now I'm bored listening to you to it and
I try to surprising it's shiny ol it's
an old man you never stop talking you
done oh yeah okay cool I play so it's
like the petulant child in it leg Oh
can't can we have can we have a
discussion about I think y'all right oh
okay genuinely honest with you I - now I
was like looking over your shoulder what
am I gonna have 40 tonight and I got a
bit bored
that's usually what kids do when they
realize that they've just absolutely
been schooled in an argument school mate
you can say a lot of words like when
when you and the kids are like starts an
argument with a parent and their parents
like I'm gonna show you why you're a
little [ __ ] and then I can just
start screaming instead all right all
right things are starting to get
personal so we'll wrap it up there but
let us know who you think debated their
case better by voting in our poll in the
top right corner of the video or if
you're everyone games.com by putting
your thoughts in the comment section
below
it'll be your votes that decide who wins
so make yourselves heard right time for
this week's quick fire round a series of
dumb fun questions written by the rest
of the you
okay team naturally Oscar and small have
no idea what's coming their way
who would Indiana Jones have more
respect for and why Indiana Jones
fundamentally still has respect for
culture history and the rules of
archeology to some degree and in most
cases Laura also respects as well if
we're talking about Indiana Jones
respecting destruction and like being
topple out of a gun then probably Drake
I think Indiana Jones would respect both
of these however I think he feels
threatened by Nate because may is
basically just Indiana Jones but better
who would most likely give you their
last roller I mean as we've already
established selfish
yes tablished that Nate selfish he'd
keep those Rolo's he wouldn't even tell
you he's got the rollers yeah and I
would you know if you're out there for
survival laura is gonna think about how
you can both survive she'll share it
with you and you both get a bit of roll
oh who would be the most helpful to
navigate around a garden centre my man
is climbing over everything knocking it
over and destroying it chandeliers are
falling down he's short for of the staff
he's a bad employee Nathan Drake is a
bad employee am ia bad employee you are
on the verge of being fired almost every
day who would win in a fight between the
butler from Tomb Raider and the Sherpa
Tenzing from Uncharted I reckon the
butler would he's no chance have you
have you tried to kill him in in tomato
its unkillable you can lock him in a
fridge and like as far as I know the
Alfred that I locked in that fridge many
many years ago is still alive if I load
up that game you still be in there drink
that coffee yeah
remember to get your voice heard in the
poll or in the comment section below and
tell us who you think argued their case
better and if you enjoyed this episode
of vs. make sure to hit that subscribe
button as we'll have new episodes the
show every Wednesday thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you